[Music]
hello there you're watching the Press
preview a first look at what was on the
front pages as they come into us here at
Sky Center in the next half hour we'll
see what's making the headlines with a
journalist and author Christina
Patterson and also the columnist at the
article Ali Mirage lovely to see you
both thanks so much for joining us uh
well let's see what is on the front of
some of those papers and the Sunday
Times leads on a poll that has found
that more than 50 percent of people
would expect delays to their NHS
treatment if they were to fall ill
The Observer reports that unions are
coordinating strikes for this autumn in
protest against the rising cost of
living
the Sunday Mirror says five solo acts
and one group are planning to sue Simon
Cowell's firm claiming that they were
bullied on The X Factor a spokesman for
the show said it isn't aware of any
legal claims being filed against it
the Sunday Express focuses on comments
by the outgoing prime minister Boris
Johnson who has promised extra support
will be announced by his successor next
month for those struggling financially
as Energy prices saw
The Daily Star on Sunday leads on news
that the killing that the man accused of
killing nine-year-old Lilia balutit in
Lincolnshire has been stabbed in prison
it says he is lucky to have survived
the Sunday Telegraph is reporting the
prime ministerial candidate Liz truss is
mulling what it is described as a
nuclear vat cut of five percent to
tackle the cost of living crisis
the sun claims Prince Andrew's daughters
have asked Prince Charles to allow their
father to return to Royal duties neither
Buckingham Palace or a spokesman for the
Duke of York wish to comment on the
story
the Sunday people is warning that the
energy crisis could spell the end of the
Sunday roast which is costing as much as
five pounds just a cook
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code that you see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch along with us and we are joined
tonight by Christina Patterson and Ali
Mirage and thank you both so much for
giving up your Saturday evening to take
us through these papers
um let's just uh start with the Observer
and and their front page story their
lead is unions to join Force for wave of
strikes over cost of living and
Christina do you feel it is now
inevitable that we are going to have
waves of strikes over the coming few
months
but it's certainly looking like it and I
have to say it's beginning to I'm old
enough to remember doing my physics
homework by candlelight in the 70s and
it is beginning to feel like the 70s all
over again although it actually much
much worse and in the sense that the
kind of inflationary Rises we're looking
at and certainly the energy price Rises
are sort of unimaginable and
unprecedented so unite and Unison are
apparently joining forces to hold
strikes then as we know we've already
had masses of strikes on uh the trains
with the rmt and we've had the male
workers striking so it is beginning to
look as if we might have something
that's not actually a general strike but
that the unions are trying to aim for
something that has a similar effect and
whatever you think about the Rights and
Wrongs of people striking I think pretty
much everybody unless you are super rich
pretty much everybody in the country is
now extremely worried about what's
happening economically and the energy
crisis and I don't blame people at all
for thinking I'm not going to be able to
afford to pay my bills and my pay rise
or lack of it is not going to help in
any way at all to pay my bills so I
think we are looking at a very very
difficult time ahead sadly and I think
this isn't going to make Liz truss's new
job any easier Ali do you do you agree
with that I mean do you think that there
is a a lot more public sympathy perhaps
for for Strikers these days I mean it
over the last sort of 10-15 years that
when we look at things like rail strikes
Etc there's been a certain amount of
public irritation about them but I've
noticed that with the recent rail
strikes and indeed the bin men strikes
up in Edinburgh a lot of members of the
public when asked
sympathy because they too are going
through a cost of living crisis
well um earlier today I was listening to
Tracy Chapman's
1988 uh hits on uh waiting for a
revolution or talking about a revolution
which talks about the workers rising up
and claiming what's theirs and I think
if you've got a capitalist system and I
am a capitalist by the way I do believe
in the profit motive I believe in people
working hard and twirling and getting
wealthy if that's what they search used
to do but in a capitalist system you
can't have a situation where when you're
heading towards inflation of 13 and
someone at Citigroup saying we might be
adding to 18
workers suffering and not being able to
pay their energy bills which have just
gone up by eighty percent eight zero and
forecasts to rise even higher people are
rebelling and you're quite right Jane
that there hasn't been the public outcry
that you saw in the 1970s because people
understand how difficult it is for
ordinary folk to put bread on the table
and earn a crust I mean five to ten
million households in this country are
really really are looking down the
barrel of a gun effectively with these
energy price Rises and we also
appreciated during covet that it wasn't
just the white collar workers that
actually delivered for this country is
the blue collar workers the Dustbin
workers the the nurses the the people
who serve Us in all sorts of ways that
keep this country going and therefore I
do think there is a lot of empathy with
people to get a decent wage now I'm not
in favor of inflationary pay Rises
because I do think that you can enter a
wage price spiral but there has to be
sent seen in terms of these uh
discussions I think that both sites have
to come together and try and resolve
them but look The Observer is basically
saying that unite and uh Unison are
going to coordinate their action at the
trades Union Congress and meetings
coming up next month and effectively
whoever the new prime minister is and at
the moment the polling showing its list
trust they're going to have the most
horrific in trade to deal with as soon
as they take office and and if we move
on to the telegraph Christina at one
possible solution their headline uh if
it is Liz trust looking at the option of
a five percent cut in vat I in in your
mind if this were to happen would this
would this be a solution would this
actually make enough of a difference to
to people
well guess what I'm not an economist and
I'm not someone who can uh work out a
quick solution to the energy prices
which is uh pretty much uh stymying
every Western leader at the moment
though it has to be said the European
leaders seem to be doing a much much
better job and the price Rises the
energy price Rises that most countries
in Europe are facing are a fraction of
ours I mean we're looking at sort of up
to 200 percent by next next April which
is unimaginable so I don't know if this
will help but what I do know is that Liz
truss it's interesting there was people
were asked to
um give words that they associated with
list trust and a word cloud was formed
of it and Afraid some of the words that
we used were very rude and I wouldn't
dream of quoting them here but the word
that came across most strongly was
untrustworthy or untrustworthy as you
might want to say and I'm not surprised
by that because she certainly has a
reputation for flip-flopping she changed
her mind about brexit she changed her
mind about the lib domestic changed
their mind about the royal family she
seems to be changing her mind all the
time and she has been going all out to
woo the Tory party during this contest
by promising tax cuts which would
benefit that the Super Rich by far the
most I mean his thumbs are incredible
that the number of people who I think
the same amount of money would go
towards bailing out the top one percent
as would bail out the 60 some something
like that I may have got that wrong but
it was a kind of breathtaking statistic
so she has essentially been saying from
the beginning in the Tory Contest no
handouts which apart from anything else
is an incredibly offensive way of
putting it as if you know these are
people refusing to work and you know
kind of wanting to be paid by the
taxpayer to sit around and eat chocolate
what we're talking about as Ali said is
people who are working extremely hard to
earn a living who will not be able to
pay their bills and I very much doubt
there's been a couple a family friends
in the country who haven't talked about
how the hell they are going to manage to
pay these bills and what they're going
to do about it and what they're going to
have to give up so it may be that a five
percent back to cut would be pretty
radical and it's modeled on the action
that Gordon Brown took during the
financial crisis of 2008 when he cut
back temporarily by two and a half
percent and that probably would make
some difference whether it make enough
difference remains to be seen but you
certainly couldn't change her mind let's
go let's get Ali's thoughts on this but
before we run out of time on on the
subject and I mean do you think you know
aside from the border economic
principles do you think that this would
mean at least a level of help for those
who are struggling the most
well I certainly think that the handouts
no handouts policy is just not going to
work I mean this five percent vat Cuts
gonna cost about 30 billion but that's
not going to touch the sides either and
nor is this uh a scrapping of the green
energy Levy which is going to yield
about 158 quid to the average household
and reversal in Ni is not going to meet
the needs either there's going to have
to be a huge fiscal intervention here
this is on the back of the war in
Ukraine we've got the Prime Minister
telling us that Golden Days lie ahead uh
that's all very well but frankly this is
boosterish claptrap I mean the reality
is that we are suffering on the back of
the war I'm not saying that we should
not support Ukraine if that's a policy
that's been agreed upon then then the
government is going to have to step in
do a massive fiscal Intervention which
is going to cost hundreds of billions of
pounds because there's no clear idea of
how long this war is going to last it
could last months it could last years
and this is going to mean that our
children and grandchildren are going to
be paying the price for this as they are
on the back of covid and just to
conclude this point when you borrow you
have to pay interest payments interest
payments are going to be going up in a
in a world of rising interest rates to
curb inflation so people should always
remember that governments will only tax
you or borrow that's the only way that
they raise money or they can print money
which is the third way which is
absolutely appalling thing to do and in
a world of rising interest rates we are
going to have to be paying a hell of a
lot of money just to service that debt
going forward and you mentioned Boris
Johnson and this golden future he's been
talking about that is the front of the
express isn't it and Christina very
briefly I mean do you think this is as
Ali said boost boosterish claptrap that
there are good times ahead and that the
government has all got a plan he's left
it in a fantastic state
I think it's utterly offensive to say
this at this time not least because he
has done precisely nothing to help
people you know he's been a zombie PM
for the whole summer he could have
announced something he could have done
something he claimed it all had to be
left for his successor by which time it
will be too late for many in in a e uh
doctors are reporting suicide attempts
from people who say they are worried
that they already cannot afford to to
pay their their rent to buy food and to
pay their energy bills in summer so it's
frankly deeply deeply offensive I think
he's probably talking about the
lucrative office he's got to make
speeches and maybe he's got muddled up
as he very often does because he has no
IV detail but it's absolute nonsense the
next few years are going to be very very
tough and his boosterism is just deeply
deeply offensive to the British people
at this time okay Christina and Ali were
going to pause there and we're going to
take a break and coming up after the
adverts more papers including the front
of the sun on Sunday it says BP give Dad
a job on that and the rest of the papers
off the break
[Music]
welcome back you're watching the Press
preview we've been out the journalist
and author Christina Patterson and the
columnist at the article Ali Mirage and
they are taking us through their choices
of the front pages and some of the
inside pages and Ali let's start with
you this heart this half um the times
page one this is about NHS treatment
apparently now the majority of us just
expect delays when we embark on any
course of treatment with the NHS are we
just all being a little bit more
realistic
I think that's true but this uh genius
is saying that 58 of people believe that
the NHS will not be for them it not be
there for them rather if they were ill
tomorrow now that is a pretty damning
statistic I do think that we have to be
a little bit sensitive and understanding
to remember that the NHS has gone
through the most dire a couple of years
probably in its history uh dealing with
a covered backlog you know people have
been working their fingers to the Bone
and there's a 6.7 million waiting list
so I do think the public has to
understand that however the issues with
the NHS have been a long-standing are
not just linked to covert I mean the
civitas think tank had a report out
recently that just said that we spent
ten thousand pounds ahead on the NHS one
of the highest the third highest in uh
in the uh European area and we have one
of the worst outcomes in the developed
world I mean you've got a situation here
where you've got 50 000 excess deaths a
year and life expectancy one of the
worst in the developed world something
is not working somewhere it needs to be
looked at it needs to be reformed but uh
look I need some confidence at the
moment amongst the NHS workers
themselves is a very low air but there's
a huge amount of vacancies as well that
need to be filled Christina is brexit to
blame for this part of the problem
um well Jane you won't be surprised to
hear me say that yes it is they're now
madly trying to recruit nurses and
health workers from around the world and
there's a big there are big attendance
to essentially steal or poach nurses
from India and Sri Lanka where frankly
they're probably pretty needed in their
own country so but now they have to go
through complex Visa systems they're a
whole
um agencies devoted to sending people
out of fast expense to countries around
the world trying to find the workers
that were lost after brexit who could
work here legally without any visas
without any problems at all it was a
massive massive uh shooting in the foot
Enterprise and the net result has been
really bad for the NHS and I know from
people who work in the NHS at morale is
incredibly low they felt you know
clapping in the streets didn't really
cut it people felt extremely unsupported
during covid the the general sense was
the that the NHS coped with it well
actually there were plenty of places
where people were very sadly left to die
on their own they were left to die in
hospital corridors and now we have a
situation where people with heart
attacks and strokes are waiting at least
an hour for ambulances and in some cases
many many hours I I think um you know
this is not sustainable and we're just
going to have to you know kind of take
more radical action and Ali is right
that in fact we are not a very in global
terms even though the NHS there's much
to be proud of we don't perform very
well for the money we spend and I think
you know this is It's undefended but we
also it also needs to be better run and
probably fewer managers and more doctors
and more healthcare workers okay we're
going to move on because we haven't got
very long left at all just try and get a
couple more papers in the telegraph ali
um uh Jacob rees-mogg he was well known
for going into all these civil servants
officers and finding empty desks and
leaving notes on them and now he said
right we're going to sell the offices in
central London if you're not coming into
work you can work from home you can work
somewhere else Leeds Yorkshire somewhere
far away from London
well look I've got an element of
sympathy I mean Jacob Reese smog I'm not
a massive fan of uh but I do have some
sympathy with the fact that if people
are changing their working patterns and
we know that a lot of people are uh sort
of doing this hybrid working mode that
is going to put pressure on offices in
terms of space that's not being used I
mean it does cost a lot in real estate
and at the moment the government's going
to have to be finding uh Cuts wherever
it can to pay for the dark fiscal
position it's going to be confronted
with so I do have some sympathy the
issue that Jacob Reese Morgan is going
to have is that Civil Service morale is
really at a very very low ebb at the
moment and when strike action writ large
across the public sector the last thing
the government needs now is civil
servants to also be striking and also to
have their morale in the gutter further
than where it is right now okay and
finally Christina only 30 seconds left
but the sun on Sunday says someone else
has got low morale prince Andrew but
apparently his daughters are asking
Prince Charles to give him his job back
should he get his job back yeah
well good luck with that I mean you know
I think I think the reason that Andrew
has low morale is is widely known and
pretty Justified and let's just say that
you don't pay what is rumored to be a
good 10 million pounds in an out-of-port
settlement if you have done absolutely
nothing wrong so okay I'm afraid I would
say the chances of Andrew getting a job
from Charles are pretty limited okay
Christina and Ali thank you both so much
for taking us through your choices great
to talk to you this evening